so I think we're ready let's try and
we're just going to finish off this
circle geometry question from last
lesson because we ran out of time we did
1 and 2 and Wendy gonna do 3 ok so I
need some help just to get my own brain
back into this face so the first thing
I'm going to do is I'm going to add some
constructions onto here because to prove
that PR is parallel to Q s I had to do
some stuff with cyclic codes do you
remember that cyclic quadrilateral I had
to use the opposite angles and the
exterior angles so here the
constructions I'm going to make I'm
gonna have a be down here which creates
two cyclic codes one over here a B R P
and one over here a B s Q so to cyclic
quads while I'm at it I'm also going to
construct XP because I'm gonna have to
use that in a minute
I might as well use the same color
because apparently I end up proving
these are the same the same length
fetty's so there we go that's a bit wavy
but you get the idea okay so if I recall
what we did was we said let's give a PR
that angle over there let's give it a
name let's call it theta and if you have
a look at the cyclic ward in this circle
over here circle a BRP you've got this
opposite angle a br it's opposite theta
so because they're opposite angles in a
second corner or they are do you
remember what's the relationship between
them they're supplementary very good so
I'm just going to label that hundred
degrees minus theta but then you can say
hey wait this angle over here is the
exterior angle of a cyclic quad on this
side so the cyclic quad a be sq has this
as the exterior angle and the exterior
angle of a cyclic quadrilateral equals
what
yeah the opposite interior angle which
in this case here's an interior angle
here's the opposite interior angle so
there's my 180 degrees minus theta
they're the same and now I've got
between the lines that I was meant to
compare
I've got Co interior angles and lo and
behold they're supplementary that means
they're parallel okay so I'm going to
put
these guys in like so okay wonderful now
where we went from there for part two
again to do it a little bit quicker just
so that we can get on to the last part I
think it was a P equals BX that's what's
given is that right Russell on the
question paper AP equals BX yep so we
get told that this side and this side
are the same and I use those as the
basis of a congruent triangles proof
okay so if you have a look at I'm even
going to draw it this time I was in a
hurry so I didn't do it maybe on the
side here you want to draw for me
triangle AP X can you do that one hey px
it looks something like this a P X like
so and then overlapping with it I have a
ax B so it looks like this it's going
downwards like so so I'm going to put on
those equal signs and I just mentioned
this guy and this guy I also have the
fact that ax is in both triangles here
and it here so that's why I saw all I've
got two sides two sides the sides I'm
interested in the red ones are these
guys over here just gonna put a question
mark on those those are the ones I want
to prove or equal so the congruence
proof I wanted color change relied on
these angles being equal because if I
have those angles what's my arm
what's my congruence test yeah good side
angle side it's included everything is
fine so the way I did that was I had to
be a bit sneaky with these angles this
angle here PA X P a X it's made up of
two different angles okay
so here's one of them I'm gonna call
this one alpha do you remember it was
standing on the same arc as this angle
over here can you see it they're both
alpha and by similar logic because AP is
an equal chord to BX the angle standing
on those chords are also equal so here
is the angle formed by chord AP
and where is it I've even lost the who
it is here is the angle formed by chord
BX so they're equal so now I've got
these guys being both alpha plus beta
okay so tell our I got my congruence
proof and at last I can say a B equals
XP excuse me reason corresponding sides
in congruent triangles
okay so this brings us up to speed
I hope you've gotten a bit more a sense
of the question now so let's do the last
part it has to do with ar ar we want
this to be a diameter of what we want to
find I want to prove that it's a
diameter of that circle okay now one of
the things that makes it challenging is
we don't often prove something like that
we prove that things are equal all the
time we're very very good at it how do
you even go about proving that something
is a diameter okay so here's what I'm
going to do over off on the right here
I'm just gonna draw a little circle now
if you have the diameter of a circle
we don't know all that many properties
that relate specifically to diameters so
I want you guys to wrack your brains a
little bit and think what properties
could be advantageous to me that relates
to a diameter in a circle any thoughts
yeah oh very good
so admittedly I did mention there aren't
that many to choose wrong a diameter of
course divides a circle into two halves
so semi circles right and we know that
the way that we say the property is the
angle in a semi circle is a right angle
as 90 degrees okay now if you come over
to our circle a R is here so if it is a
diameter which angles are the angles in
a semicircle there's actually more than
one have a look a P R is one of them
okay and the other one is a B are both
of them if I'm if we're right should be
equal to 90 degrees okay so how do we go
about proving this look back at the
question how many you guys have the
questions maybe with you it's okay don't
worry about it I'm just gonna pinch
Russell's let me give you a clue and I
need to give you some time maybe a
minute to have a think about this before
just show you the answer the question it
starts off with it doesn't just say go
and prove it it actually gives you a bit
of extra information which we haven't
put on the diagram yet
it says AR is a tangent in fact I think
last time I drew it green I just forgot
this time AR over here is a tangent to
this circle
ooh and a s over here is attention to
that circle okay that's the only extra
clue we get that these guys are tangents
so just like you had a brainstorm for a
minute but all I meant to get to a
diameter so maybe this is a property
that can be useful to me now you know
there are tangents brace I would think
about the properties you know related
tangents you may even want to go back
into your book and see well what kinds
of things can I conclude if I have
taejun's take a minute to think about it
maybe draw some things on and see if
anything pops out too you can give you a
moment to have a go in your room